All right. Let's go ahead and try this here,
and we'll play around with it in our browser.
So right now, these 3 radio buttons have 3 different names.
Let's give them all the same name--so instead of being "q", "r", and "s",
we're going to make them "q", "q", and "q".
Okay. We Save this,
we go to our browser
and Reload the page.
Now we have our 3 radio buttons again.
And now, when I select the first one, it behaves as we expected.
And I select the second one,
and it will unselect the first one--so that's cool.
So now we can only select one option
and things work as we expected.
And when I submit the form, we see that: q=on
because that was the name of the inputs.
A major downside to this is that,
no matter which radio button I selected,
"q" still says it's equal to "on".
So that's not particularly helpful because we want to know
which radio button is selected.
Well, that is what the value parameter is for,
and let's take a look at that.
Here we are in our Editor again, and we're going to learn
about another parameter--this one's called "value".
So I'm going to add a value parameter to each of these inputs.
I'll make the first one be "one"
and I'll make the second one be "two"--
and I'll make the third one be "three".
So now we have: type="radio" name="q"--for all 3 of these,
but the first radio button has the value "one",
a second has value "two", and the third one has value "three".
Let's go ahead and try this out in our browser.
Okay. I've reloaded the form
and now I'm going to select one of these radio buttons.
Let's go with the second one, and I would like you to tell me
what happens when I click Submit.
So what will the value of the "q" parameter in the URL be
when the form is submitted with the second radio button selected?